I wanna tell you guys a little story
about the time that I met Steve Jobs and
by met I actually mean saw him from afar
I was in Cupertino having lunch the Matt
cafe at the Apple headquarters I sit
down with all of my delicious treats
laid out in front of me and I notice out
of the corner of my eye a man wearing a
beautiful black tightly fitted
turtleneck with the sweet pair of jeans
sit down now my first thought is wow
that guy kinda looks like Steve Jobs and
then I realized that I am in Cupertino
and it was Steve Jobs skiing there
freaked me out internally freaked me out
of course because I don't want to alarm
anyone
I noticed that Steve is unpacking his
lunch he sets all of his Tupperware
containers out on the table and that's
when it happened
Steve Jobs accept material and our eyes
meet at that very moment I stopped
breathing I'm not sure what to do do I
get up and say hi Steve on the other
hand had already made up his choice of
what he was going to do he gathered up
all of his temporary containers and
quickly ran away and I'm just kind of
sitting there watching as Steve runs in
the opposite direction away from me now
there's two ways that this could have
played out I could have won got up and
ran and chased after him which most
likely would have resulted in security
quickly escorting me away to jail or
potentially some sort of insane asylum
or I could have just sat there and done
nothing which is what I did
now if you guys were in that similar
situation what would you have done which
you've got up and said hi to Steve or
would you just sat there and watched him
run away from you in fear for his life
I swear I'm really not that creepy of a
person right